[Music]
hey guys
welcome to our installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts school the sorting
hat
and another than alistar mad eye moody
alistair maddai moody was a scottish
pureblood wizard
born into the moody family a family
known for producing a plethora
of amazingly talented auras in his youth
he attended hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
and later on in his life in korea true
to his family name
went on to become one of the most famous
and respected auras
of all time auras are of course members
of an elite and highly trained unit
of magical law enforcement they work for
the department of magical law
enforcement in the ministry of magic
and are trained to investigate our
crimes and detain dark witches and
wizards
while studying moody was an
exceptionally gifted student
earning the mark of exceeds expectations
in at least five of his newts
or nastily exhausting wizarding tests
and it's a good thing that he was a good
student
because becoming an aura requires it
before you are even initially considered
for the position of aura
you must first ensure that your academic
credentials are in excellent standing
the recommended newts for becoming an
aura are potions
defense against the dark arts
transfiguration herbology
and charms and the final grade on these
newts cannot
be lower than exceeds expectations
mcgonagall sums up the pursuit of the
aura career path
nicely you'd need top grades for that
said professor mcgonagall
extracting a small dark leaflet from
under the mass on her desk and opening
it
they ask for a minimum of 5 newts and
nothing under exceeds expectations grade
then you would be required to undergo a
stringent series of character and
aptitude tests
at the aura office it's a difficult
career path potter
they only take the best in fact i don't
think anybody has been taken on in the
last three years
but being an aura isn't all about the
academic side of things
auras also need to be exceptionally
strong-willed and able to act under
pressure
that is why in their aura training
prospective auras have to participate in
a series of aptitude tests
showcasing just how well they perform
under pressure it's not all achieving
top grades and shoving your head in the
books
it's also about charisma intelligence
bravery
and so much more so with all that being
said
i think that it's safe to say that
becoming an aura is an impressive feat
in and of itself but being perhaps the
most famous auras who have ever lived
moody must have truly been exceptional
one thing that's interesting
however is that alistair moody's
hogwarts house is not on record
that means we don't actually know for
sure which house he was sorted into
when he attended hogwarts i'm not
exactly sure why his house was never
disclosed
but it has been expressed that his house
was never recorded in ministry records
so what i'm going to be doing in this
video is effectively sorting moody
into the house that i feel he would fit
best the sorting ceremony is an annual
tradition at hogwarts
it occurs at the beginning of the school
year and its function is to assign new
students to one of the four houses
gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw or
slytherin
students are sorted using the sorting
hat a sentient hat that once belonged to
hogwarts founder
godric gryffindor the sorting ceremony
dates back to the beginning of hogwarts
but before the existence of the hat the
founders would sort the students
themselves
however when the founders were faced
with the realization that they wouldn't
be around forever
they combined their powers and enchanted
what we now know to be
the sorting hat recognizing that they
each valued very different traits in
students
hence the rationale for having four
houses in the first place each founder
passed on the main criteria for their
particular house
to the hat the criteria passed onto the
sorting hat can be roughly summed up in
its own words
by gryffindor the bravest were prized
far beyond the rest
for ravenclaw the cleverest would always
be the best for hufflepuff
hard workers were most worthy of
admission and power-hungry slytherin
loved those of great ambition to perform
its task the hat uses a legitimacy
which is the art of magically navigating
through a person's mind
the student places the hat on their head
and then it assigns you to a house
based on how closely you resemble one of
the four founders
and the traits they valued if the hat
senses great bravery
gryffindor is a likely choice if the hat
senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice if the hat
senses that someone is a hard worker
hufflepuff is a likely choice and
finally if the hat senses that someone
is hungry for power
then slytherin is a likely choice there
are a million more aspects to each house
than just the traits listed above
but these are good overarching traits
for getting a sense of how the houses
differ overall
to get things started i'm just going to
clear up one thing i really don't think
that mad eye was a slytherin
here's why first of all let me just say
that slytherins get a bit of a bad rap
they are often unfairly and
automatically labeled as inherently bad
witches and wizards but this really
isn't the case despite what you may
believe
being a slytherin does not mean that
you're evil and i think that a lot of
their bad reputation
comes from founder salazar siddherin's
attitude towards
blood purity on the positive side
slytherins are often very clever
very resourceful and very determined
however
dumbledore once labelled southern
students as also possessing a
certain disregard for the rules in
addition to the above qualities
they are also often very strong leaders
as shown with tom riddle and even
salazar slytherin
himself despite all the good here i
still don't think that alistair moody is
a great fit
he's a good leader but that's not the
role that he necessarily likes to assume
he doesn't care if he's in charge or not
he just wants to get the job done
he's also very clever resourceful and
determined but not
in the sly cunning way that slytherins
usually are
he just doesn't fit there next let's
look at ravenclaw
the defining characteristics of
ravenclaw house in a nutshell
are knowledge and wisdom ravenclaws are
often exceptional students with a thirst
for knowledge
and unparalleled study habits ravenclaws
are like sponges
who take in their environments and
question well everything
all aspects of life exist to be
uncovered and examined
so and do i think moody is a good fit
here not really
but does moody actively personify some
of the traits of ravenclaw
certainly moody was an excellent student
and he's definitely incredibly
wise but do those traits overpower the
other things that we might recognize
moody for
i don't think so next let's look at
hufflepuff
the defining characteristics of a
hufflepuff are that they are hardworking
wholesome trustworthy and loyal
hufflepuff often gets given a bit of a
hard time
and is sometimes criticized for being
either particularly exceptional
or clever but this is far from the truth
as hufflepuff has produced
some of the most impressive wishes and
wizards to date witches and wizards like
nymphadora
tonks newt scamander and cedric diggory
were all hufflepuffs
and they were all incredibly impressive
so does moody fit
here i think there's a good chance but
first
let's look at gryffindor the classic
defining character trait of gryffindor
is bravery something that is exhibited
by the trio
time and time again throughout the
series gryffindors are brave
courageous fearless and every other
descriptor that fits that category
bravery for gryffindors is valued above
all other traits
and we certainly know that if harry
hadn't been brave then the wizarding
world would have turned out a lot
differently so is moody more gryffindor
or hufflepuff
though i think arguments could be made
for either i'm going to go with
gryffindor
here's why alistair moody was an aura a
dark wizard catcher and it was once
stated that half the cells in azkaban
were filled thanks to him
day after day moody put his life on a
line in order to secure a safer
and more prosperous wizarding world and
he did it entirely selflessly
and without fear moody shows us time and
time again that he's not afraid of
anything
and that he will always put his own life
on the line if it means achieving
something meaningful
something that will contribute to the
greater good of the wizarding world
when i think of moody i think of pure
unadulterated
valiant bravery and i can't think of a
better house to fit that
than gryffindor he's ultimately killed
putting his own life on the line
to save harry and in turn the wizarding
world and he truly died a hero's death
what do you guys think do you agree with
this where would you sort moody
who should i do this for next let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you